ce
bonjour à tous rival région 27 ans une
opr de jeux vidéo alors on dirait pas
comme ça mais j'ai vécu pas mal de trucs
dans ma vie à 8 ans j'ai apprivoisé un
renard à 10 ans
à dix ans j'avais une épée géante et je
me battais contre des multinationales
qui cherchait à tromper d'énergie de la
terre
à 12 ans
à 12 ans à 12 ans mon but était de
devenir le plus grand dj de mon village
alors là vous vous dites alors là vous
vous dites bon l'huile est complètement
fou qu'est ce qu'il raconte espérait
mais en fait pas du tout tout ce que je
vous raconte jeunes et bien vécu et je
n'ai vécu à travers des fictions à
travers l'empathie que en a pour des
personnages on peut vivre des
expériences qu'on n'aurait pas pu vivre
autrement et c'est là de pouvoir des
fictions pour vous illustrer la
puissance que ça peut avoir
on va faire un petit jeu est ce que vous
pouvez imaginer brave heart
william wallace les écossais contre les
anglais s'est fait rare et donc vous
voyez
quelque chose comme ça maintenant si je
vous dis
que william wallace ce héros là qui
porte ce magnifique titre
eh ben le kit est arrivé trois cents ans
après les évènements du film là vous
comprenez que avec une fiction on peut
réécrire l'histoire
dans l'imaginaire collectif
avec une bd comme v pour vendetta on
peut inspirer un mouvement
révolutionnaire
avec des romans comme 1984 le meilleur
des mondes on peut avoir une critique
exacerbée acérée des dérives de notre
société
et en parlant de terribles de société
récemment vous avez discuté avec des
jeunes
ici à martinique
qu est ce qui ressort
ben moi je dirais une certaine forme de
désespérance
bon d'accord c'est pas propre à notre
petite île 1 s'est un peu partout en ce
moment mais j'ai l'impression que nous à
nous frappent particulièrement
parce que on un territoire enclavé on
n'a pas forcément beaucoup de chance de
vivre de nouvelles expériences
et tout ça en fait ça veut ferme des
portes vers l'espoir
et en fait je pense que c'est exactement
là que la fiction a tout son rôle
elle nous permet d'ouvrir des champs des
possibles
et pour illustrer à quel point c c'est
le cas je vous parlais d'une jeune laura
mary d'une benoît américaines les plus
jeunes maintenant
qui a grandi dans un ghetto noir
américain en fait
à l'époque
tu es jeune les rêves c'était pour les
autres et puis la découverte des romans
de normand fantastique
les livres de science-fiction et là elle
a commencé
à ouvrir ses rêves avoir de nouveaux
objectifs par la suite elle a fait de m
haïti une des écoles les plus
prestigieuses au monde
et aujourd'hui ayant bien compris
l'importance qu'ont eue les fictions
dans sa bible elle écrit des livres
fantastiques pour les enfants et la
petite subtilité c'est que tous les
héros viennent d'un peu partout dans le
monde
et ce n'est pas hasard parce qu'elle
s'est rendue compte d'un gros problème
c'est qu'il ya des gros problème de
représentation dans les oeuvres à grand
succès
et pour vous le montrez je vais analyser
trois oeuvres qui ont eu beaucoup de
succès
j'ai commencé par harry potter alors
harry potter comptes reconnaît c'est
peut-être pas tout le monde mais c'est
450 millions 10 vendus à travers le
monde
ces huit films qui ont cartonné et
dedans si on s'amuse à chronométrer le
temps de parole de tous les personnages
non blancs les noirs les asiatiques les
indiens sur 1200 minutes de longs
métrages
d'après vous il ya peu près combien de
temps de parole pour ses personnages
ok c'est pas mal semaine quatre minutes
50 secondes quatre minutes 50 secondes
en tout pour 1200 minutes de film ça
c'est quand même assez impressionnant ça
fait 0 3% quoi
par contre il ya une communauté qui est
souvent moquée presse opprimés qui a
beaucoup de temps de parole ce sont les
roues dans le seigneur des anneaux donc
pour ceux qui connaissent patients des
anneaux c'est des livres qui ont inspiré
un pan entier du fantastique c'est trois
films qui ont cartonné au box office ou
six
et globalement des cultures sont
clairement identifiables à l'europe la
crise inspirations viennent de nos
mythes nordiques mais il ya une culture
qui est clairement identifiable à des
nord africains
ils viennent du sud ils ont la peau mate
ils ont le visage voilé et chevauchent
des éléphants ce sont les arts a dream
le petit souci
c'est que ils sont du côté des méchants
et qu'ils ont tendance à se faire
dégommer en cinq minutes de film
ici world of warcraft est ce qu'il ya
des joueurs de world of warcraft ici par
hasard ça vient vous allez pour des
choses un peu différemment maintenant
dans l'univers de warcraft il ya
plusieurs races donc c'est un jeu qui
cartonne beaucoup et qui est assez
symptomatique de tout un univers de tout
un imaginaire ya plusieurs races donc
comme vous voyez l'espèce de gros
taureau vaches là en bas c'est un
torrent
il est clairement identifiable à la
culture amérindienne parce que ils
prient les totems et il en communion
avec l'esprit de la nature au centre la
jeune femme est clairement identifiable
en fait aux cultures européennes par
leur architecture par le fait qu'ils
prient dans des cathédrales la lumière
et c est le truc tout moche la violer
passer non
ce sont les afro antillais flux lieu
près du vote il de ils ont des rituels
vaudous
danse d'acapulco il prononce pas les
airs et le petit truc dérangeant dans la
représentation c'est que sentent mauvais
ils sont agressifs cannibales et pas
très malin
voilà c'est ça l'image qu'on a donnée
et adore pour rendre cendre tout ça je
les comprimés c'était un petit peu
intuitif
alors je me suis dit on va essayer de
théoriser ça et de le rendre mesurable
objectif alors j'ai créé le un test un
essaim critères pour mesurer le degré de
bonne implantation d euros
je l'appuie le tc du méchant chamelle
alors bien ce titre qui claque ou pas je
dirais que ya quatre critères c est ce
qu il existe des cultures non
occidentales
est ce qu'elles sont aussi importantes à
l'histoire ou est-ce qu'elles sont
complètement secondaire est ce que est
ce qu elles sont aussi humanoïdes ou
est-ce qu'elles sont représentés par des
grosses par des gros taureau comme tout
à l'heure où par des géants bleus comme
dans avatar
et est ce que leur degré de moralité et
équivalents c'est à dire ce qu'ils sont
aussi bons ou mauvais et en fait les
résultats sont assez sidérant ça paraît
être d un test plutôt basique à une
époque où on parle autant d'égalité sauf
que la plupart de nos oeuvres à grande
succès ne ne passe pas
oh
et j'en ai discuté avec des artistes des
auteurs qui ont grandi dans l'hexagone
je leur ai parlé de tout ça ils m'ont
dit
mais bon sang mais comment j'ai fait
pour ne pas voir que ces terrasses
et c'est là le truc c'est qu'en fait on
répète inlassablement des clichés des
automatismes qu'on ne remet plus en
question
quelque part c'est ça qui est choquant
c'est que ça nous choque on a intégré
que le héros de d'avoir une certaine
apparence et que certaines cultures
était fait pour être secondaire voire
néfaste
si on regarde un petit peu le message
que nous envoie la plupart de ses
oeuvres
c'est toi antillais ou indiens ou quoi
tu n'es pas le héros tu peux être un
personnage secondaire si tu veux le
meilleur ami le superviseur mais tu n'es
pas le héros est ta culture
et soit secondaire soit barba
oui
et donc
le truc c'est que
pour briser des clichés il faut être
capable d'être à l'intérieur d'une
culture parce que ceux qui en sont à
l'extérieur n'ont pas accès à toutes les
subtilités qui permette vient remettre
en question
alors du coup cette année
c'est à nous de nous représenter c'est à
nous de créer des oeuvres qui nous
représente
c'est à nous de briser le statu quo
mais avant de se faire
il faut déjà questionné nos vieilles
habitudes on pourra commencer par
exemple par notre cher compère lapin
alors partir de maintenant je vais vous
montrer des illustrations qui ont été
faites par des jeunes étudiants
martiniquais ici c'est des gars ch'ti
couriol alors qu'on perd la passe est un
personnage récurrent de nos comptes et
du côté clair de la force de compère
lapin c'est un débrouillard
il est vraiment un ingénieux sait faire
des blagues mais il s'en sort
le côté obscur de compère lapin
si que il va pas hésité à sacrifier des
autres pour se sauver lui même
et ce sont les gens de valeur qu'on
transmet à travers nos comptes
tout ça on peut leur pensée parce que ça
s'explique à l'époque d' esclavage
à cette époque les actions collectives
ont été réprimées par le sang et donc
ceux qui réussissent à s'en sortir donc
ce qui a été valorisé ce sont ceux qui
essaient de se débrouiller par eux-mêmes
à passer entre les mailles du filet
je me demande si aujourd'hui on essaye
de travailler ensemble de créer des
sociétés collaborative
est ce que avoir un personnage qui est
entre guillemets un héros ou transmet ce
genre de valeurs est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est toujours aussi pertinents l'autre
chose qu'on peut remettre en question
c'est notre magico religieux si je vous
dis chouval toi pattes
dans l'iss soulignant moment clos
hadja blesse
d'après vous est-ce que vous êtes déjà
demandé pourquoi toutes ces entités
ils cherchent soit nous violer soit nous
tuer soit les deux
alors certains vont dire bravo c'est
normal parce que bon on est gla pas bon
quoi alors oui bien sûr on est
génétiquement programmés pour avoir des
imaginaires négatif quoi mais tout ça
c'est pas sérieux
en fait encore une fois on trouve la
source de sa à l'époque d' esclavage
parce que avec la culture des esclaves a
été estampillé comme diaboliques
parce que l'ordre établi avaient bien
compris le cerf donner une force une
force mentale et une unité des visions
positives
du fait que cet imaginaire s'est
construit principalement dans une
période extrêmement violente
le chose qu'on peut aussi
penser c'est notre rapport à l esclavage
alors évidemment l'esclavagé je sais pas
c'est vraiment une période importante de
notre histoire il faut pas négliger mais
je me demande si à chaque fois concrète
des oeuvres fantastiques à chaque fois
que l'on a quelque chose qui nous
appartient en tant que club de fiction
est-ce qu'il faut que presque
systématiquement ça soit par rapport à
l' esclavage
est ce que dans ce conte est un jeune et
qu'on a enfin une oeuvre de fiction qui
nous intéresse qui parlent de nous
est-ce que c'est exaltant comme à venir
de ce2 d'être projeté dans un univers
aussi anxiogène et violent
alors à ça j'ai cherché de nouvelles
pistes
parce que on peut repenser beaucoup de
choses
avant de se faire je vais vous car faire
petit jeu encore est ce que vous pouvez
imaginer une noble princesse
imaginez une noble princesse
bon la tête bon alors
je suis pas mentaliste je suis pas devin
mais je suis presque sûr que 90% d'entre
vous ont vu une blonde avec les yeux
bleus un petit diadème sur la tête qui
m'ont vu venir aussi mais sinon c'est ce
qu'on voit d'emballement on a peut-être
cinq ou six qui ont vu une princesse
indienne mais ça c'est parce que il
regarde trop de bollywood quoi mais
sinon on aura avancé ça
et peut-être que sûr par contre c'est
que très peu d'entre vous ont vu quelque
chose comme ça
une princesse africaine une illustration
ici de brigitte bardot
c'est yennenga
une princesse guerrière un personnage
fort qui a créé sa propre nation qui
menaient des hommes qui a repoussé des
assaillants pourquoi alors on nous dit
que la plupart de nos ancêtres sont
africains mais pourquoi encore une fois
on en revient toujours à l' esclavage
quand on parle de leur histoire pourquoi
on revient pas à l'histoire précoloniale
à l'époque des royaumes les empires
africains de tout ce qu'ils ont créé en
terme de philosophie de civilisation
d'économie leurs contes et légendes leur
héros ça existe tout ça on peut
l'exploiter
l'autre chose à laquelle on peut
réfléchir à nouveau
c'est notre magico religieux ici par
exemple on peut imaginer des moments de
l'eau qui qu'est-ce qu'on aurait sur
notre rapport à la nature qui nous
ferait la voir de façon mystérieuse
oui ok ce que tout le temps en train
d'essayer de couler les navires et de
tuer les mains
en fait quand on y réfléchit c'est
peut-être ça la force de notre oralité
on a une culture qui est transmise à
l'oral
et ce qui est bien c'est que rien n'est
grave et un est gravé dans le marbre
on peut si on veut rayer maginez nos
mythes et ça a été fait plusieurs fois
on peut imaginer nos mythes
mais on n'est pas obligé de se contenter
du magic aux religieux parce qu'en fait
ce serait très restrictif
on peut promouvoir des valeurs liées à
la technique et la technologie
exemple ici on n'a ni version
totalement fantasmée les deux françois
bas rhin
de futurs qui serait à la fois roots
pirates technologique pourrait pêcher
des poissons volants
enfin bref on fait ce qu'on veut
en bon à ce niveau là normalement on se
dit bon qui imagine r c'est vachement
important ça conditionne beaucoup de
choses
et puis on peut pas vraiment compter sur
les autres pour bien nous représenter
chose c'est que on commence à avoir des
pistes mais comment on va faire pour
entre guillemets concurrencer ces
mastodontes et blockbuster qui nous
viennent des états unis et d'europe
rires comment y arriver je vais vous
dire ce qui va se passer ce qui va se
passer c'est que nous les artistes et ça
je le compte là je constate déjà
on va pas faire nos compères lapin on va
travailler ensemble on va être aussi
malin que lui mais on va travailler
ensemble on va partager nos idées
elles seront de plus en plus forte de
plus en plus belle on va créer un nouvel
engouement pour notre propre imaginaire
ça va créer des synergies et quelque
part les messages qu'on droit à
transcrire qu'on aura à transmettre à
nous mêmes
ça sera un devoir pour nous mais aussi
pour le monde parce qu'on a des choses à
apporter au monde
notre philosophe et poète rené ménil
c'est la réalité et l'imaginaire se pose
donc pas comme l'être et le néant mais
comme l'être et le devenir
ma grande idée pour ma petite île et
j'espère que maintenant c'est notre
grande idée pour notre petite île
c'est de nous réapproprier notre
imaginaire
nous réapproprier notre destin merci
les